we in america
pride ourselves on our free press we
have a free press unlike those
oppressive countries you know there's
really bad countries where they have
state-controlled media well we have a
totally free press that's at least what
our press tells us
and yet i watched the news
and i have to tell you sometimes i
wonder if we wouldn't have a more honest
media if we were living in north korea i
watched this clip yesterday from
kob 4 so it's one of these local news
affiliates a local news affiliate in new
mexico running a segment a news segment
on how you're supposed to completely
change all your language to deny reality
let's talk about dei in the workplace
and that's better known as diversity
equity and inclusion how do we go about
the discussion of pronouns so
essentially the employee will reach out
and say hey this is my preferred pronoun
this is how i would like to be
addressed in the workplace how we go
about it is by respecting their request
right so you want to make sure when they
say this is what i would like to be
referred to
um we address it and we we honor that
and we uh moving forward use that term
whether it's he she
they them their whatever they would like
to use we want to make sure we honor
that request and make them feel
comfortable in the workplace is it
appropriate for someone to ask what
someone's preferred pronoun usages are
you probably wouldn't want to ask that
person would ask you okay so you know if
you
if they haven't fully made the decision
on what pronoun they would like to use
let them come around to that decision
and then ask
if they haven't asked yet it's not safe
to assume we don't want to make any
assumptions we don't want to make any
assumptions that's great let's talk a
little bit more about
all of the language that people should
use and if they don't use that language
how they'll they're very bad people and
they'll be fired and how we need to deny
reality and call men women and women men
i would find the media more credible
if they were talking about how kim
il-sung is the eternal leader of north
korea and is still alive governing his
people from the heavens
that would that is
at least
as
fantastical
or at least as realistic as what you're
seeing here from the new mexico news
station
in fact in many ways the
state-controlled media in north korea
and china and russia and wherever all of
all of these terrible places on earth in
in some ways they're more honest because
at least you know okay this is state-run
media so take it with a grain of salt in
america it's it's in many ways worse
because they pretend to be a free press
and yet they push this kind of madness
this kind of corporate establishment
absurd
dishonest
madness
that is propaganda david hogg you
remember david hogg you might not
remember david hogg he was the kid who
was at the school where there was a
shooting in florida and i don't even i
don't think he was even particularly
close to the shooting itself
but he managed to be one of the first
kids to race to get on television
afterward and he's made something of a
career out of that he managed to get
into harvard strictly on the celebrity
that he got out of
out of this
tragedy and so david hogg he's been out
of the news for a while he's not really
such a cute kid anymore he's gotten a
little bit older and so now to try to
get some of that celebrity back
he interrupted the house judiciary
hearing to yell and scream about guns
the shooter at my high school
anti-semitic anti-black and racist the
shooter in el paso described it as an
invasion guess what those guns are
coming from the united states of america
they are coming from mexico
they are
not coming from mexico you are
reiterating the flights of a mass
shooter sir sir you are perpetuating
this violence you need to be like a
snobby mouse a democratic
stop these things now
it's sad when the footlights start to
fade
isn't it it's kind of sad for people
when the celebrity starts to go away and
people stop caring you can even tell
there when david's yelling and yelling
he's speaking like he's at a political
rally
but no one was supporting him even his
own guys weren't supporting him
so he was waiting he gets to that point
so these guns are coming from the united
states and he was waiting for applause
and there was no applause and people
weren't even looking at him and then he
starts to stumble on his words there
these are not it's not coming from
mexico it's like a child actor who grows
up
and he was under the misapprehension
that that people liked him because he's
some great actor when really they only
liked him because he's a child and it's
the same thing here this guy was being
used by the democrats because when he
was 16
he was useful to them
and they could put these cute little
kids on tv and the kids were pushing all
the democrat gun talking points but now
you know he's got some whiskers he's
older what is he 19 or 20 now it's just
not
doesn't play as well and so they don't
care this is what democrats do
democrats
use people
when they are useful to them and then
they chew them up and eat them up and
spit them out
and i think it's i don't think i'm being
unfair here i think this is part of the
lib world view that views people not as
children of god made the image of
likeness of god with dignity that should
be respected as eternal beings but as
just kind of fodder is just kind of
things to be used for their own benefit
and those things they talk about how
much they love the people and power to
the people but really the people they
need to shut up and eat the bugs and
stay in their little pods and they
shouldn't own anything and because
us great tesla owners we need to be able
to thrive and they need to keep their
mouths quiet and if there's too many of
them and we don't like the way they look
and we don't like where they're being
bored we're just going to kill them
we're going to and we're going to
discourage them from being conceived in
the first place
and they can't have their beliefs
they're going to try to cling bitterly
to their second amendment rights and
their religious views but it's
ridiculous they're just they're nothing
they're nothing to me they should be
cast out into the outer darkness where
there's wailing and gnashing of teeth
that's that's one way of viewing the
world a view of the world that is
divorced from
community from honesty from integrity
from from
from the truth from objective reality
that's a vision of the world in which
the truth means nothing and even the
fact checkers are just going to spin
spin spin and lie lie lie so long as it
gives them more power
guys i am so close to hitting a million
subscribers and that's going to make me
feel really great and then i'm going to
get a big gold play button and then i'm
going to put it up right outside my
office and i'm going to i'm going to
make sure that everybody walks by and if
they only have that silver youtube play
button i will i will mock and deride
them i will make them feel small i will
i will laugh and go fall in their face
so please help me to have that pleasure
subscribe ring the bell we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]